what politician is going to save me and
in reality no politician is going to
save you personal responsibility is
extremely important what's happening
with the big Banks what's happening with
the ESG score the international
multinational corporations running
things is far more important especially
when it comes to your own individual
decisions that you make in everyday life
and I think this is why that message is
so much more important because
everyone's like please someone save us
in reality the only person who's going
to save you is you yourself and and you
know you've taken many steps
homeschooling you opened up a
homeschooling Network as well can you
tell us how that is going and how people
could potentially be involved in that
well it's the Ron Paul Curriculum you
just get on the website there and the
school did has done sped it steady and
does well but there was a big burst of
interest you know during coven but some
of the people went back to the
government schools uh you know after
that